bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuto questo
video siano dal sud led out dopo una
settimana come sempre però in premi
fattivo perché sono non è il massimo
buona visione qual è allora mi scusi io
posso anche uscire di qua io esco grazie
è stato meraviglioso primo sbloccato un
hotel fighissimo vediamo cosa ci faceva
un fucile minchia di youtuber anche tu
sei la blogger io sono felice faccio
gameplay secondo me quelli che ci hanno
da registare un bel po di roba e tra un
po io ve lo dico giusto predict le
parole leggono almeno l'hotel alex bello
che tu possa entrare in un hotel
completamente random e vedere centrale
le stanze ma se chi se ne frega
senza un ritegno ciao sarò mi ha
spaventato pensavo fossi amy
vediamolo vieni sai da sola ma vai non
correre rischi e non corre nessun
rischio vado io
c'è un tavolo qua scherzavo tramite
usare l'ascensore non c'è l'ascensore ha
sì c'è l'ascensore di là quindi usiamo
l'ascensore speriamo che satana non
compaia nella ecco partito fuori un
filmato il che significa che ci abbiamo
proprio nel culo ma livelli
[Musica]
un gioco di sguardi cosa sta succedendo
raga cos'è sta roba
vi prego è passato con sisca e lei no e
che devo pagare da stamattina e non ho
ancora trovato un cesso pulito atto
quanto caccia molto bene sono tornati in
questo regno devo trovarla subito mi
occuperò di sis capitarvi mi dai un
attimo di tregua già vedo nostri già
vediamo mostri perfetto ce l'abbiamo nel
culo in tempo zero che è sempre la
solita storia mai dar confidenza a
questi stronzi di fantasmi via c'è uno
grosso e non posso uscire se devo andare
avanti o andare i guai
meno male che funziona sul player forse
per questo sarei già morto 66 volte
siamo qua dentro le scuole non so
neanche dove sto andando paci sto
andando l'importante quello siamo in un
hotel del cacchio lo bene e comunque è
fantastico che non abbia mai successo
no non è vero la strada sbagliata d'onda
di sotto non sto dicendo comunque
fantastico che non abbia mai visitato un
posto senza che diventasse una roba
horror pesanti c'è un gatto vedete io
vado un'ascia una grazie amici è proprio
quello di cui hanno bisogno
lascia grazie dice ma quale ascia mag i
media la vista un'ascia ci ha dato un
ascia al gatto ma dove hanno visto il
suo lasciano scusami quando grazie a
mano a cagare prima vista andiamo lì
sopra possiamo questa di sopra oppure
fatto qua spacco qua faccio a vado giù
spacco giu spacco su se come lo spaccare
la porta questa cosa 8 mag e o perfetto
buongiorno fu cristo
lo spettacolo ayane non si è preso il
danno
niente a fasciate christian raga tutto
chiuso aiuto è tutto più che è posto del
ca vorrei veramente tornare a casa mia
dove c'è quella megera maledetta con le
sigarette
siete botta ai a garantire attivate in
attivo di tutti io sento bene giorni
canto non è il massimo delle situazioni
questo ma fa niente
corri c'è un ascensore li corri vivevo
video non lo prende
che cacchio come fuori servizio ma
veramente non ci voglio credere
ma sotto la t indietro no perché non ho
capito ti prego fai in più di una scala
ok una l'abbiamo fatta è già un buon
risultato possiamo arrivare almeno la
seconda no siamo dati erano e testa di
minchia la porta è bloccata se qualche
tipo di combinazione forse dovrei
cercare le altre stanze basta non è che
devo illuminare qua per terra eccolo
questi numeri potrebbero essere utili
vai 39 23 06 32 230 sintra 223 06 32
tedesco 23 madonna che cosa brutta 23 06
32 ma il problema non è tanto il codice
è ma chi è venuto in mente di scrive lo
per terra in una stanza mio dio
ricordo lo vogliono ma ricordo che lo
mette in automatico meno male giorno a
posto sono i blogger di prima sono stato
talmente non abbiamo trovato nessuna
prova l'esistenza di iscritti oscuri ma
va mai mulà sordina corda forse posso
usarla per scendere vai ti prego arriva
al piano zero ti prego
oddio oddio dire che cos'è ma chi è
questo che questa roba qua bilancia si
esce
sono morto ma non puoi mai mettere dei
mostri appena le one minchia non ho
fatto niente
vai verso le scale antincendio un po vai
verso l'ascensore un po pescante
incendio finché continui a scendere
tutto così male
buongiorno poteva scendere grazie per la
visita però che ho fatto già fuori una
volta non mi rompere le palle piano 6
quale stiamo scegliendo un sacco ragazzi
forse riusciamo arrivare no allora la
prima questa porta o no per il culo non
mi sembra un piano allegro però siamo al
piano terra ok a posto sappiano terra ce
l'abbiamo fatta
l'abbiamo fatta non mi sputa niente a
lato non mi sputa niente ce l'ho fatta
c'è un occhietto ma che cazzo prima non
era chiuso sai chi si era stato ce l'ha
proprio scritto che cazzo quindi chi
sarà stato è da un paio di nomi in uno è
belzebù l'ha autorizzata ce n'è un altro
paio poteri di cole devo andare io di
sopra ma dai ma da eva con sé le chiavi
cioè le chiavi in mano
scusi le chiami hai tu riuscirà qua
guarda è stata la mia fortuna che la tua
porta allo scontro a chiave in una di
queste stanno se vai a cercarlo ora
prima che sia troppo tardi vado grazie 6
gentile ovunque io ti chiami non me ne
fregava una sega rata cerchiamo la
chiave vi desse un nano demoniaco deve
darmi la le indicazioni ma cosa ne so io
civati pare poi ovviamente non avrà
messa in una realtà
le ultime a giudicare quella da due
sentire liquidi questa eccola perfetto
c'è anche excel aperto per le fatture ma
questa è la chiave il blocchetto come
minimo l'ho trovata ok perfetto c'è
qualcuno qua si che fa che cacchio è ai
a testa di minchia di un nano bastardo
vieni qua o no dai ragazzi no no no no
di qualità di quel prodotto pezzente
schifoso di loreto al caf le charlot chi
devo flashare ma veramente resta che è
diventato davvero a mano tu non suonare
il clarinetto testa di culo il clou cool
e le quello che era al terzo piano
campionato di perdita
ti do una sciatta di quelle tele di
qualità buongiorno e vabbè ho capito non
lo prendo fratello ti devi fermare temi
tanto magari non me l'ha neanche preso
la chiave non ho controllo dato sulla
fine dotto e ragazzi di fermate il
vostro giovanni qua agli accorga [ __ ]
che botta
la prima volta di apri la porta a lidia
aprire questa porta del campo
siamo veramente scesi nel poco la musica
né che dici gioco e trash non la musica
anche signori eccoci qua nano royal con
quello grosso ma e al fratello tutto ok
adesso ho vinto io
ragazzi se volete vedere con soli
costano ancora vivo tra the list è
[ __ ] chiavi del cazzo deve ancora
brook lopez sente schifo tendo altre
morto molto diversi da vista chiave
padrone no ti prego non morire la data
ma mi fai uscire la sto maledetto
trivago fatemi uscire a questo ascensore
scusatemi londra ancora più eccola se
non di spuntare non mi scusi niente vi
ammazzo di fico lasciata nel naso dentro
il naso grafico che gioco orribile cioè
nel senso
per chi la chiama tilapia però c'è
guarda tempo per la chiave madonna se
succede qualcosa se la sbrighi te io me
ne frega niente
meno male
no no
no no no ti ammazzo ti divido in
pezzettini a2a 2 finchè non diventano
dispari continua a dividersi
allora coste boss fight delle palle that
you sorella morta che è successo ma
[ __ ] che succede
è che cacchio ho capito ma i semi del
portale ma eccolo dove canta o fa tutto
26 piani per niente ho fatto ma la poi
ancora colpire ben visibile
minchia saperlo quindi lei diventa solo
invisibile non studenti scompare
comunque fra nadal e gasquet
mamma
o che è nuda nuda a tutti i nudi che è
successo
inizia india minchia fragala massacrato
se in un appartamento
basta mori muori basta basta
vai su happy meals bastano per palla mi
è basta
[Musica]
guarda nino materi
ambiente in quanto che è ora di fare le
scale o mio dio guarda la perché è
ricoperta di sangue non ho ragazzi è di
scena cosa è tutto così reale dovrebbe
informare la polizia
sì sì bravi formata la polizia stato
dove l'uscita teste di minchia poi i
vostri video delle palle maledetti
youtuber del a posso andare io veloce ok
portiere ma è calma quindi ragazzi anche
oggi fishel episodi di tre doubts e un
quasi verso la fine spero che vi stia
piacendo a me moltissimo infatti a parte
e spero che vi sia piaciuto come se non
ti piace evidenziare solisti siete come
sempre ci hanno passione e ragazzi
[Musica]